any object in our world has its own
expected life cycle
this lifespan may be comparatively short
for some objects
while others will be around forever
almost literally
in comparison with the life expectancy
of these objects an average human life
seems to pass in the blink of an eye
but what will the autumn years of such
objects as stars look like
and will we ever be able to observe what
a dying star is like
will mankind ever see the so-called
black dwarf
[Music]
the term stellar evolution in astronomy
refers to the sequence of changes that a
star undergoes throughout its
entire life this process largely depends
on the object's initial mass
and may take anything from several
million to tens of billions of years
as a rule a star originates from a cloud
of code
low-pressure interstellar gas due to
gravitational instability
the cloud compresses and eventually
slowly assumes a spherical shape
during the compression process the
gravitational field energy is
transformed into heat and radiation
with the temperature of the young star
gradually going up
the duration of this stage depends
directly on the star's initial mass
with the heaviest stars it may take
about a hundred thousand years
and with the lightest ones the phase may
last up to several billion years
our sun's mass for instance is
comparatively small
and so it remained in this first phase
for approximately 110 million years
in the next phase after a sufficiently
high temperature has been reached to the
core
thermonuclear fusion takes place inside
the star
and the compression ceases after this
the processes taking place at the core
become the star's only energy source
and thus a young star which is also
called a protester
becomes a main sequence star this is the
starting point for calculating a star's
age
as this phase accounts for approximately
ninety percent of its life cycle
our sun for example will remain in the
main sequence stage for approximately
eleven and a half
billion years when a star enters its
main sequence stage
its chemical composition is still very
close to interstellar environment
and is 91 hydrogen at the same time the
process of hydrogen transforming into
helium is constantly in progress
inside the star as a result the core
compresses
and gains in density which gradually
increases the rate of chemical reactions
it leads to noticeable changes in the
star's properties
for example the luminosity of our sun in
the main sequence stage accounted for
only 70 percent of its luminosity today
by the time the stage is over the
luminosity is going to be 2.2 times that
of today
it should be mentioned that not all
stars make it to the main sequence
stage the exceptions known to science
today
are referred to as code and hot
subdwarves
these objects are very similar to main
sequence stars but they do differ from
them
thus by contrast subdwarves are not rich
in heavy elements
and are not so luminous the final phase
for main sequence stars
also depends on their mass generally a
star either discards its outer coat thus
becoming a white dwarf
or goes supernova to later become a
neutron star or a black hole
a supernova is a phenomenon when a
star's luminosity dramatically
intensifies
with great amounts of energy released
during the process
after that the flare slowly fades
this explosion is accompanied by
emissions of great amounts of matter
from the outer coat
the remaining matter in the core of the
star god supernova
generally forms a compact object either
a neutron star
or a black hole apart from everything
else
the matter released in the course of a
supernova event
contains products of thermonuclear
synthesis
it is thanks to these elements that the
universe is able to evolutionize
chemistry wise
if a star's mass doesn't quite reach
eight sun masses however
this main sequence star will end up
being a white dwarf
that is an object which is a hot
celestial body of small dimensions
and a high density for instance in the
case with our sun
when the time comes for it to go through
this phase it is going to become a
hundred times smaller than it is now
white dwarfs do not generate energy and
are luminous
only on account of their high
temperature even though the hottest
white dwarfs surfaces may be as
scorching as 70 000 kelvins
due to their small size their luminosity
is not that great
as for their average density it is
almost a million times that of the
regular density of main sequence stars
these objects consist for the most part
of a plasma of nuclei
and electrons and are completely devoid
of thermonuclear energy sources
which is why they gradually cool off and
assume a red hue
sirius b is the closest white dwarf to
us that we currently know of
and it is 8.6 light years away
this object's mass is give or take that
of the sun
and is considered to be one of the most
massive white dwarfs known today
its volume is a millionth of that of the
sun and its dimensions are identical to
those of our earth sirius b is believed
to have become a white dwarf
approximately 120 million years ago
with the initial mass of the star in its
main sequence phase having been
five sun masses today it is positive
that these objects account for three to
ten percent of the overall stellar
population of our galaxy according to
different estimates
over 97 percent of the stars known today
are eventually destined to become white
dwarfs
as time goes by these objects are bound
to cool off and fade
eventually all celestial bodies of this
variety will become black dwarves
which implies that they will completely
cease to emit any visible light
this process takes scores of billions of
years
that is why to date science hasn't had a
chance to observe any of these objects
the universe is considered to be too
young to have produced any black dwarves
at this point
but scientists have already managed to
spot objects quite similar to them
whose temperature has gone down lower
than 4000
kelvins these objects are white dwarfs
wd0346 plus 246
and sdss j110 217
a black dwarf is what most stars look
like at the final stage of their
revolution
its mass is quite identical to that of a
white dwarf
according to today's models
demonstrating cooling of these bodies
white dwarves formed in the course of
the evolution of the first generation of
stars
are supposed to have a temperature of
approximately 3
200 kelvins and to appear as rather dim
objects for all we know
these celestial bodies could be part of
the universe's hidden mass components
for a white dwarf to cool off to the
temperature as low as 5
kelvins it may take approximately 1
quadrillion years
in theory when black dwarves cool off
completely
the process of dark matter annihilation
becomes very important for their
existence
this phenomenon hasn't been directly
observed in the universe yet
although it is thought that in the
course of annihilation particles of dark
matter will form ordinary photons
and emit light visible through a
telescope
without allowing for this phenomenon
black dwarves are believed to cool off
and fade to the point where their
temperature equals the background
temperature of the universe
however in theory thanks to the energy
derived from dark matter annihilation
black dwarves may well continue to
radiate energy for a considerably longer
period
and thus enjoy their luminosity longer
the process of dark matter annihilation
in these objects
is thought to continue for as long as
the galactic halo remains whole
and that means over a septillion years
after that dark matter annihilation
gradually ceases
and only then will black dwarves cool
off completely
it is likely that mankind will never be
able to discover objects of this kind
as the main period of their life takes
place in the face and the life of our
universe
which will come after the one we're in
at the moment
the period we live in is a starry park
that is the period where stars are still
born
quite actively this epoch will last up
until the point when the galaxies will
deplete
all of their interstellar gas
after that it will be the turn of
low-mass stars like our sun to fade
following that a long period of
disintegration will begin
when white brown and black dwarves are
the main objects populating the universe
at the next stage the epoch of black
holes
all matter in the universe will be
transformed into elementary or subatomic
particles
with the remaining black dwarves getting
sucked in by black holes
or completely disintegrating
the final stage in the life of the
universe is supposed to be the epoch of
eternal darkness
where there won't be any energy sources
whatsoever in space
the overall temperature in the universe
will reach absolute zero
space will gradually expand and in the
light of the last and rare black holes
in about one google years our world will
come to its gloomy
end by that time all traces of what was
once
the human civilization would have become
nothing
however if we can influence the process
of the universe's evolution
in any way the course of its life may be
significantly altered
meanwhile as you watch the cosmo channel
you motivate me to tell you all about it
as mankind keeps taking a keen interest
in prospects for the future
and this means that even after such an
unthinkably long time
there is a chance for us to leave our
mark in the infinite expanses
of our universe
[Music]
you